interupt you there because we're going
back to the peace Summit in Cairo let's
listen in the civilians completely we
ask the national Community to adopt a
concrete pressure on Israel and we
refuse the double standard practiced by
some parties on the international level
we need a serious move we ask the
International Community to pressure
Israel to lift the
on Gaza to stop the military operation
that has
killed a lot of civilians we reject
categorically any forced relocation for
the Palestinians I'd like to express our
disappointment because of the failure of
the security Council towards this matter
this
crisis your excellencies your majesties
your highness is we ask for an immediate
humanitarian safe corridors for the
international and National humanitarian
assistances to reach the people of Gaza
so as not to aggravate the current
situation need to support the
Palestinian people to restore its
legitimate rights and to have his
sovereign state on the Palestinian
territories of 196 7 according to the
international resolutions the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia was since the very
beginning to coordinate with its
Partners in order to sort out the
problem and we hope this Summit will
urge the International Community to move
quickly to sort and solve out the
problem for the Palestinians to and the
Israelis to have a serious Dialogue on
the Palestinian cuse we need peace that
is lasting and comprehensive for the
sake and Welfare of everyone the kingdom
will continue its efforts in order to
reach this goal the utmost priority now
is a ceas fire we need to stop the
Bloodshed we need to help those in need
we need to pave the way for uh uh
circumstances that will lead to peace
peace be upon you
all thank you very
much
Prince fan foreign minister of the
Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia floor goes
to forign Minister of
Turkey his Excellency Mr President
distinguished heads of state and
government dear colleagues
excellencies this is a crucial juncture
where Bloodshed prevails over restraint
and Common Sense last couple of weeks
have all already left an indelible Mark
in our
minds many of us still find it difficult
to believe what has been
unfolding thousands of innocent
civilians are losing their lives in
front of our
eyes the situation in Palestine has
always been a tragedy now it is turning
into
Carnage there can be no excuse or reason
for inflicting such a collective and
cruel suffering on human lives like the
one happening in
Gaza we must be un unequivocal in
condemning and resisting loss of any
single innocent
life International Community has to
calibrate its actions and messages at
this highly critical
point Israel should be urged that the
temporary so-called victories did not
bring long-term Security in the course
of history it will not bring this time
too
Israel exploits the solidarity of some
countries as an open check for
unleashing a blind rage on Palestinians
such a Rage which even targets mosques
and
hospitals on the other hand I would like
to remind that unconditional military
aid to Israel or csing Regional
countries to unrealistic and
unsustainable plans serve nothing but
deepening
occupation because these policies omit
neglect and ignore a vital part of the
equation the
Palestinians insistence on such errors
are in fact another sign that the
current International order cannot
produce solution to core
problems what this order produces is
only erosion of universal values and
Distortion of facts on the ground upon
until now Israel took advantage of this
systemic
failure Israel distor the sanctity of M
delaa and the the status quo of the
Muslim and Christian holy size in jarus
Salam but Brands it as religious
tolerance Israel grabs the lands homes
and livehoods of Palestinians in East
Jerusalem and West Bank but brand is as
civilian
settlements Israel imprisons 2 million
people in gaza's Naro C unfit for decent
human life but calls it as a protection
against terrorism
by dehumanizing Palestinian lives Israel
aims to normalize Palestinian suffering
We Say Never Never for Palestines
Palestines never for anybody else if
allowed this crisis can spark Wars of
global scale through geographical
escalation but it can also serve as a
ground for just and Lasting peace
therefore at this historic juncture we
have to set the track right
turkey believes that a right track
begins with the sensation of hostilities
and unconditional humanitarian Aid to
Gaza simultaneously we have to
revitalize every effort to return to a
peace process based on a two-state
solution an independent Sovereign and
cious state of Palestine along 1967
borders with East Jerusalem as its
capital is not only a must for peace it
is also the Strategic imperative for
International Security and
stability I am sure we all agree on this
however it is not enough we have to go
beyond AG green and start implementing
this Vision furthermore there should be
an guarantee mechanism for monitoring
verifying when needed and forcing
obligations of the parties in a just
peace turkey remains ready to further
develop this concept and share the
responsibility for creating a dignified
just and secure future for all our
heartfelt gratitude goes to Egypt for
this much timely Gathering thank you
very
[Applause]
much
okay you have been watching the uh peace
Summit in Cairo which has been led by
the Egyptian president abdal fata Al CI
who is trying to organize some sort of
humanitarian uh ceasefire in Gaza as we
see more bombardments rain down on the
Gaza Strip over the last few hours
[Music]
well it's just after 11: GMT that's 2:
p.m. in Gaza where humanitarian Aid is
finally being delivered through the
rougher Crossing with Egypt it's taken
15 days and intense International
diplomacy but now trucks from the red
Cresent carrying food and Medicine are
on the Move Hamas says 20 vehicles are
entering on Saturday it's not clear how
many more will be allowed in with 2
weeks into the war there's no let up in
Israel's bombardment of Gaza the Army
has ordered the evacuation of 20
hospitals in the north ahead of possible
air strikes hundreds of Palestinians
have been killed in the past 24 hours
the total number since the strikes began
is more than
4,200 the attacks by Hamas killed at
least 1,400
Israelis diplomatic efforts to end the
violence are intensifying as we
mentioned Egypt is hosting world leaders
at a summit in
Cairo Egypt expresses its astonishment
that the entire world is watching a
humanitarian catastrophe that victimize
2.3 million people in Gaza Strip that
they are collectively punished they are
under siege and the lack of the basic
need of life and
relocation in practices that has been
denounced by the modern
world well also speaking at the Cairo
peace Summit was United Nations
Secretary General Antonio gues he spoke
about his visit to the Rafa border
crossing I went to the Rafa border
crossing there I saw a paradox a
humanitarian catastrophe playing out in
real time on one hand I saw hundreds of
trucks theming with food and other
essential
supplies on the other hand we know that
just across the border there are 2
million people without water food fuel
electricity and
Medicine children mothers the elderly
the sick full trucks on one side EMP